the studios are going to look back at
the strike and say it was the worst
thing that ever happened to them
because what were the conversations you
were having with the writers during the
strike I mean there was a lot of
darkness and fear I mean it was a it was
a long strike and it it didn't look good
in the beginning let's give a little bit
of a perspective
so when there's a war the generals will
look at the last war to see what worked
and they'll replicate that and usually
that's a good idea sometimes that's how
Empires fall so in 2008 which was the
last serious work stoppage that the
writers said the writer
strike um at that point reality TV was
starting to grow in popularity and so
the whole thing about a strike and I'm
sure you know most of you listening to
know this what happens is when there's a
strike it will not resolve until both
sides want it to resolve so both sides
have to be in enough pain pain that
they're like let's figure out a solution
if one side wants a solution and one is
like let's keep the strike going it's
going to keep going okay so what
happened is in 2008 the the networks the
powers that be said well we can't get
any scripted you know content so let's
just triple down on reality TV and
hopefully we'll get similar ratings well
it was better than that for them they
got almost identical ratings and it's a
lot cheaper to do a reality TV so
suddenly they were like you know what we
like this strike so the writers in 2008
were really struggling um you know and I
was making my living as a writer back
then so it's really hard when you can't
you know get a paycheck and so we're
like Hey Y'all let let's talk and
they're like nah we're good you you you
keep picketing like you you go for it
you spunky writers we're just going to
do reality TV and it it got to the point
where we had such little leverage you
know our guilds amazing and they got the
best deal they could but it was a bad
deal because we didn't have the leverage
okay so when the two 2023 strike happens
uh the networks are like well let's pull
out the old Playbook and the head of
Netflix Pretty uh arrogantly I could use
a different word but I won't uh
arrogantly said ah we're just G to
Triple down on reality
TV and then of course the thing that
saved us was the actors if the actors
hadn't gone on strike and the producers
were desperately trying to peel them off
and and get them to a deal because
without them we would have been left out
in the cold so that was a huge turning
point so the actors go on strike we
haven't struck together the writers and
the actors like in 60 years this is a
big deal but the powers that be and I'm
just going to use Netflix as the example
because they are the evil death star in
this story Netflix is like we're just
going to do reality TV we're we're just
going to do foreign um now Netflix has
all the data in the world they know more
about us than we know and after a month
they abruptly stopped spending that
money they cut the cord why because they
know or they knew it wasn't working why
wasn't it working in 2008 most of the
audience had been watching Network TV
network TV got really bad in the 990s
and in into the 2000s there were a few
good shows but most of it was just the
same old formulaic junk and if that's
what you've been watching reality TV in
some ways was a step up because in 2008
reality TV was still early so it was no
you know it was novel and unique and
there was some interesting reality TV
shows and the audience was pretty much
like yeah we'll do this well what
happens in 2023 I mean an entire
Generation Now of the viewers they've
grown up ironically because of Netflix
Netflix has spent 17 billion dollars a
year for the past five years everyone's
racing to catch up there's been so much
money yeah a lot of junk has been made
but some amazing stuff has been made
amazing content like flea bag and
Breaking Bad and Russian doll and the
bear and I can go on and on and on okay
so an audience that's watching that when
you suddenly say hey pay for your
subscription and here's what we're going
to give you more reality TV you're going
to be able to watch the housewives of
South Dakota or whatever I mean you're
just going to get more reality TV than
you can this is going to be awesome
right and like no thank you and People
canceled their Netflix subscriptions and
canceled their Hulu subscriptions and
they stopped watching and they tuned out
and that terrified the industry because
if they tune out where are they going
and maybe where they're going they're
going to want to stay there so
suddenly everything changed and it went
from we we came out of the darkness of
the strike of this is going to go on
forever we're probably going to get a
bad deal this is horrible and there was
a lot of economic pain out there and
suddenly we came into the light because
suddenly they're like hey let's get this
done like let's get a deal done and
we're like great here's our terms and
they're like okay but we got to Neo no
no these are our terms and it's even
better than that and the reason it's
even better than that is I think that
because we were on the picket line with
the actors and we had real solidarity
and we realized something we realized we
don't need the suits we don't need
Netflix what is Netflix it is an online
Blockbuster Video it's just housing
content TV shows movies we don't care
about Netflix we care about the TV shows
and the
movies now anyone anyone who's watching
this who's on the younger side you might
want to Google Blockbuster Video
Blockbuster Video was a 800 lb corporate
entity that was just minting profit and
then someone came along and destroyed
them and that someone was called Netflix
Netflix came in and said there's no more
Monopoly there's no more Monopoly on
distribution anyone can make stuff and
show it uh via these platforms and
suddenly the TV industry doesn't have a
monopoly the studios don't have a
monopoly um Blockbuster Video doesn't it
disrupted everything okay but then
Netflix of course invited all this
competition and suddenly now the reality
is why do we even need Netflix in fact
why do we need the studios so here's
something that just happened and you're
going to see a lot more of this Taylor
Swift has a movie and she decided I'm
not going to the studios to distribute
my movie because why would I I don't
need them she just went to the theaters
and said you want really good content
right people seem to like me right now I
have a movie you want to negotiate and
they're like yeah who's a distributor
and she's like me and she just cut the
studios completely out
now we don't have right now that you
know we don't have the social media pull
or you know we don't have the social t
that Taylor Swift does okay so she was
the first to do this but there was so
many conversations with writers on this
on the um the picket line and you're
going to see
this back in the day a bunch of uh
actors and directors created their own
artist friendly company called United
Artists this is like back in the what
40s or 50s 1940s or 50s what's going to
happen is they're going to be
showrunners big writers big actors
they're going to get together and say
let's create our own platform it's not
that expensive and we can easily raise
the money and we'll have an artist
friendly platform that treats artists
the right way and we will get all our
friends showrunners and actors and
directors to exclusively make content
for us like we don't need Netflix like
again anyone could create a online uh
streaming platform it's not I mean it's
not that hard to do anymore what matters
is the TV shows and the movies it's the
entertainment is the content that's what
matters well who controls that we do the
actors do the writers do the directors
do we control that the studios are going
to look back at the strike and say it
was the worst thing that ever happened
to them because I was a working writer
for 12 years and I can tell you the way
the game is played is they always had
control and they use scarcity of jobs to
their advantage and they pitted us
against each other I always felt I mean
I had I have and had friends as writers
but for the most part I often saw other
writers as
competition they wanted that they wanted
us to be competing against each other
and they had complete control because if
you want if you had a movie or a TV show
you needed them to show it to the world
we don't need that anymore and being on
the picket line together
suffering together we realize we're
artists we are you're my sister you're
my brother man that solidarity is not
going away I mean the writers are like
we're not going back to work until you s
we're not crossing the actor picket line
they supported us we're supporting them
we're on a team and you know what we're
the team that makes the world go around
we're the ones that make everything that
people want to
watch I'm telling you the the the
studios blew it they thought they could
crush us and what they did is they woke
up a sleeping giant and we realize now
that we don't really need
them okay so then if there was let's say
this uh you know actor sort of filmmaker
Alliance that that comes together and
forms its own sort of unofficial studio
democratized studio eventually though
don't you think then a hierarchy is
going to form and then rules and then
you know it could become the same
situation where you have people at the
top dictating and pulling all the shots
so well here's I it's a great question
here's what I would say
um
uh can can I can I tell you a true story
that will lead into my point sure okay
there's a lot of stories out there about
how terrible Hollywood is and how they
treat people horribly I was a working
writer for 9 years years I have the
scars to prove it and um I could tell
you some really terrible stories but I'm
not going to I want to tell you a really
great story I was a young writer and
there was a project at Paramount this is
back when Sher lansine was running
Paramount and they had this project they
were interested in but they could never
figure out how to do it they couldn't
figure out how to take and there was
they kind of had it in the back pile and
there was a young executive who really
loved this project and he was a young
executive so he couldn't work on the
prestigious stuff and he's like can I
champion this project and so Sherry said
yes and I'll give you a budget of
$100,000 which means he could hire a
writer for up to $100,000 so he wasn't
going to get an experienced writer he
wasn't to get a big WR so you know he
wasn't going to get Aon sorcin or anyone
of that El so he needed to get a newer
writer so it becomes an open assignment
and agencies can say hey I got the
perfect person here they are I read
their script and I was one of those
people and the producers this is
important it's Trilogy it was they're
producers and it was called Trilogy
entertainment I think they're still
around and um so they brought me in and
I did my pitch and it just really landed
the executive was like oh my God this is
like even better than we realized this
is really cool I can't wait to tell Sher
So at their next meeting when they went
around the room he's like hey I've got I
heard a really great take for that
project she's like okay let me hear it
and he he did you know summary of the
take and Sherry got really excited and
she's like now this is going to be a big
summer movie all right I'll give you a
million dollars go get a real writer now
you're the producers who do you want
writing the
script a guy right out of film school no
real credits unproven or a million dooll
writer I mean you get Aaron sorin or you
know a bigname writer to write the
script suddenly it has cache suddenly
stars and directors like obviously you
want the million doll writer so that
basically meant I was going to get you
know what over I mean I came up with the
take and now that they realized this
opportunity they were going to just hire
a million dollar writer to write it and
I get nothing and this kind of thing
does happen except Trilogy said to
Sherry well wait a minute Corey came up
with the
take you now want to spend a million
dollars we got a problem but we we've
come up with a solution pay Corey a
million dollars and you have a million
dooll writer I wish the punchline was
she said yes no she did not say Yes um
and they went around circles and she
says no I've got a list of writers and
they said well look we're the producers
Cory came up with the take he deserves
the first crack you're going to pay him
and he's going to write it and if he
Nails it we're going to make it and if
he doesn't then you can go get your
writer but we're sticking by our guy now
is this in their interest not not at all
why did they do it they started out as
writers these were writers who became
producers I've worked for production
companies where the people in charge
were writers and it is a different
experience when the people in charge
went to NBA schools or
suits so these new writer collectives
these artist friendly they're going to
be created by writers and actors for
writers and actors and they're going to
create a set of rules that are artist
friendly and it's it's not only morally
right it's going to be very smart
business because the best writers and
the best actors are going to want to
come and do content and do projects I
mean during the strike there
were major movie stars there were right
major showrunners who like have
literally hundreds of millions of
dollars in the bank this strike isn't
affecting them at all and they weren't
out in their Italian uh vacation homes
you know what they were doing in a very
hot summer they're walking the picket
lines and they weren't doing it for
publicity they weren't doing it to be
noticed they were doing it in solidarity
because they were a starving writer they
were a middle level writer or actor they
understand so I really believe that
these new entities that are
formed they're going to treat writers
and actors the right way it's not going
to be about creating as much profit for
shareholders it's going to be I I
predict that they will take a certain
portion of the profits and reinvest it
into new projects with new emerging
talent I think it's going to be
wonderful